una lancha contra bahador s
stratocaster restaurant
so cute Oh happy birthday by the way
you're welcome oh thank you birthday
amber in Mexico awesome Mexico
oh it's only so today we are at Kabbalah
the largest lake in all of Mexico and
today is Papa 10th birthday so hopefully
he has an awesome birthday here in
chapala and i didn't notice but my dad
and my aunt are actually on their way so
we get to spend the whole day together
as a family
[Music]
ice cream ice cream was your weird hey
giggles but it doesn't break so it's
like it's kind of like a cello kind of
feel oh really good very very
interesting
[Music]
you look really cool
u.s. candies burglary no their tamarind
candy but I've never seen a mango
flavored tamarind candies but I bought
it all right I'll give it a try
usually I do not need snack like this
but I'll give a try like a candy mmm
JJ oh really good Oh yummy
he's really a fat one hmm we bought what
he wanted
ah yes skiddo this is what he asked me
to buy American candy but you're like oh
that's what I should've grabbed I told
you traveling is all about experiencing
things you can get this will be exactly
we've been struggling again Isaac to try
new foods and to try new candy new
drinks do everything I think been
playing it safe on the trip which is
riches reasonable most people want to
play it today but because it's
travelling because he's so young we from
trying to get him to try new stuff and
open his mind up to new things
and it's been very very very hard to do
that so far it's really cool to see my
dad opening up to new cultures because
growing up he's always hated 1pg just
ate junk food and he always hated junk
food growing up we never meet my brother
we never ate junk food because he never
liked junk food let me go to movie
theater he won't buy anything from the
concession stand he will throw a fit if
they
that for bugs to buy solder I think a
long time ago tune you has always been
like Chinese food is number one Chinese
anything is number one and to see him
opening up now it makes me feel very
good right here a nice food over there
pickle me latina Chinese restaurant
[Music]
Isaac's getting to the age where he's
starting to become closer to a teenager
age and he's starting to want to be cool
I'm gonna try and sneak some shots where
he's trying to be all cool like in his
own little world meeting the tips with
lemon and duckie
[Music]
fun down the stylus so my aunt and my
dad are on their way and my answer is
they're going to try to stop by cake
please pick up a little kick for your
dad to me
esta la rumba ding ding ding ding ding
do you my favorite kind of cake ever see
really what type of fragrance a tres
leches typically from every here is my
first real tres leches cake from Mexico
[Music]
propene adil espanol hola
high-five all right we are now in the
town of McCullough we were met by this
little kid that was kind of uh surest
into a parking lot is really cute you're
just running after it's running and
running and running after it anyhow so
hard out here high five twenty pesos for
the two cars we gave him ten so then my
grandma's like he can easily sit up look
at the hard worker fancy that's why I
want Isaac to realize how good of a
lighting a given registers just set like
what what just happens I think but
unless what's wrong
Vicky's old little boy was bunny trying
to get us to park in his parking lot he
was a hard worker that little boy
doesn't have an iPad
he doesn't have a lot of it he doesn't
have a TV in his room he doesn't have
anything he's over here struggling to
make a dollar you should appreciate your
life because if not look look how other
kids live they don't get to travel they
get stuck in this tiny little town you
get to travel you do the world you take
everything for granted should appreciate
so funny Isaac walks in with my
colourful sunglasses a nice button-up
shirt hair slicked back
nice shorts and shoes and these kids are
shirtless shoeless running around in the
water fishing and stuff so it's a stark
contrast hopefully hopefully Isaac takes
away something I don't know we'll see
[Music]
you're gonna eat first I'm actually
excited about this meal because I really
really like seafood and I ordered some
fish today and after that though we're
gonna hop on the boat and we're gonna go
over to that Island that's over there
right across my view while I'm eating
right now we go over that Island and
actually haven't gotten word of what
we're actually doing on the island but
I'm excited this right now is right fish
what do you want no no you won
let's try it we got I don't know mm it's
like a chip it's like a fish chip you
want to make $100 girl quick mr. chance
fry fish
I'm being serious I'll give you $100
it's like a chip okay you can't do it I
can't do it
when cool retro let's do it
yeah I get oh do it
oh yeah it takes bad giving up
[Music]
I'll be bout to go on this boat to get
that Island straight ahead in that
Island
it's kind of like a Mexican alga chat
I'm multitasking
[Music]
you
we're testing Tiff's ability to speak
Spanish in English Hamilton's the egg
once again
she's our translator I found a old 1800
light bottle with beer bottle humor of
an eight year old oh my god
[Music]
it smells like sweat here but that's not
it's a material that they made this with
cactus juices
they do the kitchen a Big Mac and the
fries and a coke okay we're good
[Music]
my business my dad said so your dad
didn't want to sit with the other one
she was like no it's my birthday I don't
want to sit but then he's fine taking
photos big boobs skeleton why didn't you
want to stay with the other one it was
scary
hi there was a guy and these are happy -
we are into like a budget that's another
city within will Anahata but they're
famous were here it's like sour Thyssen
all AKA we going shopping this is
coconut water fresh coconut
I like the one ice cube they put on top
to keep it cold I know it's the only one
it's so funny the live is the Friday
night the city's alive yeah so much of
this zero for how you know create into
your nine minutes things I'll find a way
I chopped it up like to touch it out
[Music]
bubble bath smells really good yeah you
do I didn't smell it I didn't smell it
[Music]
no it's very messy
that was my sister Suellen so when I
lived here in Mexico I lived with her
and I worked with her and I party with
her so we were like tight so she's like
my my most beloved sister EVER it's so
nice to finally see her again finally
because it's already Friday we leave on
Monday this whole time she's been stuck
at work and I've been telling her like
it's not fair I came over here to see
you like you're to see my dad and just
be my sister so and I'm like those are
the main people I came to see and I'm
like it's not fair I haven't seen you
you're so stuck at work every single day
I have any missing you for dinner to
like I know I'm so sorry
but finally I made it on like final
he-men I'm a little leaving already
yeah I'm so happy I finally get to see
her - last time you saw her was
literally when we first got serious
about our relationship we were living
together at the morning yeah when we
first got serious that was last time
sorry my sister my my little niece her
name is Gabby I love me
[Music]
nice to meet you again yeah I get ya she
has the same eyes every I'd look alike
yeah it's on my desk I with family we
all have the same lies like for sure you
guys are gonna plug your I don't even
believe she's tired
Oh stick Baxter better yep get well wall
Wilson Avignon and yellow is
brother-in-law God basically I need you
brother-in-law
that's a octopus ceviche my dad ever
liked me shave and even warm up to it
pretty soon Emma phone Isaac
do you understand your cousin but you
know how to play together huh doesn't
matter what country you're in u.s.
Mexico China England Germany Spain all
kids communicate on the same wavelength
when the cons to video games minecraft
is the universal language for children
Oh
clown hmm your dad likes I'm going to
try this plan it's a little bit a little
bit of salt and when put all that chalk
[Music]
[Applause]
when we first got here I was mostly
excited because I just wanted to see my
family already like that I just had like
that yearning to just hug my dad and my
grandma like my hands and just my whole
family I was just so excited to see them
aside from visiting Hong Kong where my
relatives are I don't think I've
actually had such a first-hand
experience exploring another country and
thanks to your family I feel like we
were able to see the stuff that most
tourists will never get a chance to see
because we didn't even do any of the
work we didn't do any research we just
kind of got our plane tickets and
arrived and and then
BAM we had a whole like tour of Mexico
and it was through the lens of a local -
not through an agency not through tour
guide during something that and I felt
like that was probably the most valuable
thing that we could have had and so yeah
I actually really appreciated everything
that your family did the hospitality
that we showed and and their willingness
to take time out of their day to kind of
show us the country I think was even
more beautiful than the country itself
with your family dynamic and how they
embraced you know my family it's been
amazing I never imagined that I would
have this much fun especially with both
of our parents meeting and seeing their
interactions together and seeing how our
families kind of collided and how
accepting your parents have been of my
culture and how accepting my family has
been your parents just been so beautiful
and even though I am getting a little
bit homesick I mean this experience has
been so beautiful that I kind of don't
want it to end and I think this has got
to be the most memorable and you know
what the best vacation I've had loved it
[Music]
[Applause]
Spanish happy raising no Armani more but
it's a lot longer but that's where we're
gonna stop